the coroner's office is a vitally
important agency here in southern nevada
these teams
are some of the first people to talk to
a grieving family and share crucial
information of public officials
kate houston sat down with our new clark
county coroner about her goals for the
department
and what stands out about cases in our
area what i can bring
is a new perspective if anything and
really
sort of polish the things that we
already have in place and kind of fine
tune some of the processes
for the past 15 years melanie rouse has
diligently worked her way to a director
level
coming from the phoenix area the climate
and case volume is similar to las vegas
but rao says the amount of tourists are
not we don't always have
readily available the next of kin that
we need to talk to
or the records or things like that that
we may need to review as part of our
investigation
rouse wants to continue to utilize the
relationships they made with other
public agencies during the pandemic
we work again to build and prepare and
have those relationships ahead so that
in the future
we already have those contacts in place
we understand what the processes are
and we can start addressing it early on
another focal point
bringing in the next generation of
medical examiners
as the first female coroner in clark
county rouse hopes to inspire
students to go down this career path i
am still learning
every single day of my career there's
always something new that's going to
present itself there's always
new developments in technology and
science that
really can drive forward this field
which i think is very exciting
kate houston 8 news now right now there
is a national shortage of medical
examiners the clark county coroner's
office is
actively recruiting for a wide variety
of positions they also offer
internship and educational opportunities
for students